it turns out that Avengers endgames
writers don't simply have a soft spot
for deadly green alien warriors in a
recent interview with cinema blend
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
revealed that they had a specific reason
for including the return of Gamora and
their script so the character would be
available for James Gunn to use in the
upcoming guardians of the galaxy vol 3
your recorder of the many many shocking
deaths to be featured in Avengers
infinity war the Morris was one that
seemed as if it would be permanent she
was forced to accompany her adoptive
father Thanos to the planet for Mia
where anyone brave and/or determined
enough could acquire the soul stone for
a price
Thanos was informed what a stones
protector that in order to possess a
stone one must give up what they love
and it just so happened the only thing
that I was loved in the universe his
daughter was standing right next to him
I ignored my destiny once I cannot do
that again even
for you fellows hesitated for the
briefest moments before chucking
Gomorrah down to a doom from one of
Vermeer's rocky cliffs securing the
stone and eventually succeeding in his
mission to snap half of all life in the
universe out of existence gomorrah
however like loki and home doll who met
their ends and the film's brutal opening
scene didn't perish in the snap but was
killed outright by Thanos or so her
death was the price for securing the
soul stone and as we learned when black
widows sacrificed herself so that
hawkeye could get his hands on that very
stone during the events of Avengers
endgame such a death cannot be reversed
Markus and McFeely however found a way
around that problem by using the
Avengers time-traveling endgame
shenanigans to reintroduce the 2014
version of Gamora one who had not yet
met up with the Guardians in ascribes
conversation with cinema blend McFeely
clarified that that particular element
was basically put in place so that gun
could have his entire team on deck four
Guardians three he explained there are
parts in endgame that were written so
that gun could do whatever he needs to
do McFeely also referenced a poignant
endgame deleted scene that made it clear
that 2014 Gamora wanted nothing further
to do with anyone
he said you saw the behind the scenes
stuff for the O'Neil and Gamora sort of
Bugis offset if the filmmakers are left
that in he would have gone oh she's
alive and she's over there it's very
vague now I don't know what gun is going
to do with that well neither do we but
us never stopped us from speculating
2014 Gamora pointedly does not take off
with the Guardians
at the conclusion of endgame and really
why would she she has no idea who these
people even are where could she be
heading off to parts unknown obviously
but with her adoptive father gone and a
relationship with Peter quelled never
having been forged there's really only
one person in the galaxy she has any
kind of kinship with her sister nebula
who is currently tagging along with the
guardians should fight one another from
the honor of Lucien sounds fair
it's not necessary not perhaps Gamora
will seek out nebula in an attempt to
get some answers about what in hell
exactly happen with Thanos
and the weird army of super-powered
Terrans or maybe she'll head off into
some forbidding corner of the galaxy and
get herself into a germ the kind of gem
that her friends will be compelled to
help bail her out off even if she
doesn't exactly know them yet
it's worth noting that gun wasn't
blindsided by gamora's fate and infinity
war but was totally in the loop as to
what Markus and McFeely intended to do
with his character meaning that he's had
plenty of time to mull over where to
take her arc in guardians 3 it would
absolutely shock us of the deadliest
woman in the galaxy was anything but key
to the plot of the third Guardians movie
heck perhaps you'll even somehow find a
way to rediscover the memories of a
alternate timeline self the one who died
so that her father might succeed in this
terrible mission it would take some
pretty hardcore narrative acrobatics but
if anyone is capable of pulling those
off without shattering our suspension of
disbelief it's gone in any event the
situation interestingly illustrates a
kind of synergy necessary for all of
these amazing franchises to exist within
the same shared universe and as McFeely
noted the extent to which filmmakers
must be content to simply pass the ball
to the next person to continue this
story of any given character but fili
said I like that little dangling piece
of time-travel the bow wasn't completely
wrapped up and there was a little bit of
an after effect I don't know how it's
going to affect the coming Guardians but
just leaving some strings when you're
trying up this many strings it's
satisfying to know that there are a few
still dangling for as long as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe exists that is to say
until the earth is actually swallowed up
by Galactus it seems likely that there
will always be a few strings left for
the next filmmaker in line to tug on as
far as this one goes we're going to go
ahead and guess our Guardians 3 will
seek will remember his way to Kimora's
hearts through the musical stylings of
Elvin Bishop his melodies are pleasant
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one